in the world of first person shooters
one thing has always remained constant
you almost always want to shoot the
other person right in the head i'm gonna
take one headshot for blackbeard to kill
them but it's gonna take four head shots
for the opponent to kill you
okay just forget about sieges blackbeard
for a second seeing that headshot icon
in the kill feed is proof to us all that
yeah
you're pretty good at this whole aiming
thing so with all that said join me now
for the top 10 headshots of all time
coming in at number 10 we've got the
infamous happy deagle ace now if you're
good at clicking heads the desert eagle
can get you out of all sorts of sticky
situations and after losing an eco round
to tsm at dreamhack open london 2015
envy was strapped for cash and looking
for a way to regain the momentum enter
happy who stopped tsm dead in their
tracks and stunned the cs go world
they're taking their sweet time hoping
to catch somebody peak on envy's side
and well that's what happens when you go
around the corner happy with juan dig oh
and another one
[Applause]
debris is like sweating bullets
he's gonna get the quad killing
what is this with four of these kills
coming by way of head shots this is an
impressive play that won't be replicated
anytime soon
bullet penetration has been a
long-standing feature in counter-strike
but still few people expect to be hit
through a wall at long distance in the
head from the enemy spawn two rounds in
a row so at number nine is a pair of
wall bang headshots so filthy that the
lineup had to be patched out of the map
after body showed it off at esl pro
league that's when my valve made the
decisions on this map they kind of just
work with them right yeah of course yeah
yeah but but it was it was done when the
reasoning was done
that really just hit i wasn't really
looking away where's that gone that was
from
through the top of the roof in as if
things couldn't go from bad to worse
like he said a difficult round
considering bonnie's trying it again
oh no
no way no way you can't possibly do that
twice in a row even though it was
removed the remake of cash allowed some
warbang lineups like this to return and
for a little treat here's the french
call of it the hype is really
we've got four head shots and a surgical
defense from fleeta the scariest version
of overwatch's widowmaker is the one
where she isn't pressured at all because
an expert marksman can rip apart the
enemy team with ease from a position of
safety overwatch league superstar fleeta
put this on display during the overwatch
league's may melee this one down once
and for all fearless hunting for targets
he looks like a lost school buy in the
field being bullied for his shorts but
prett fled are now moving over onto the
widowmaker taking the clutch into his
own hands the perfect timing on the
brigitte the flick onto the sombra he
even manages to salvage the old charge
from the jumping ana and diva this is
truly an impressive melon smashing
sequence and it's no surprise that
fleeta was named the overwatch league
mvp in 2020
cs go has graffiti for iconic plays but
valerian hasn't yet done something
similar so the next best thing is having
your play immortalized in the call outs
that pros use every day to practice
which is why at number seven is a
headshot a so filthy that the position
subrosa got it from now bears his own
name as a map call out
this is gonna be huge
he's gonna spot all of them right now
one two three
looking for the ace right now and it's
about to be peaked out here
so barrel to come out and he's gonna win
this fight and he does with another
headshot the olaf boost levels of
confusion here are palpable as sub rosa
unloads from his sneaky spot so now when
someone gives you a he's subrosa call
out on ascent you'll know exactly why
among those who make their living
popping domes only one has the moniker
the headshot machine and his name is
scream the belgian rifler's wantout
prowess is well known but his confidence
seemed equal to his ability and nowhere
was this more clearly demonstrated than
in our number six clip at the first cs
summit in 2017 action for the uh so
that's what i was talking about earlier
as well
the one for short yeah he's got one
bullet in it he's three legs got one
bullet oh
scream
just scream things that was on purpose
pete the ammo counter here that magazine
is completely empty he's got just the
one in the chamber and even though he
had a chance to reload he chose to
commit to the one tab now that is a
stylish headshot that sends a message
pistol clutches can be pretty difficult
under the best of circumstances but try
it again simple and you're liable to
just get blown out which is why and
number five play here is from esl one
new york 2016 that not only has a
legendary caster call but is a massive
1v4 clutch in its own right and all the
kills come via headshots but it comes
out worse for where in the end neo gone
guardian wraps back around that it's
gonna be bialy down in the end to just
snacks does find one let's not leave him
out of this the big apple and snacks is
hungry he's got one kill already on the
usp low hp as well on guardian and flame
he's trying to bait them out trying to
get them into one on ones as he dances
back and forth between the box what a
shot on simple oh guardian bye bye and
it's on the flaming he's tapped it
in flaming name is that from stacks
apparently snacks credited pasha with a
lot of the call-outs heading into this
situation but he still had to hit those
crispy pistol shots and boy did he hit
him
at number four we've got carpe's widow
putting on a master class in head shots
in overwatch league stage four week one
where he manages to save the entire map
in the process to escape too if you get
jumped on but it looks like the boston
uprising is too busy trying to take the
point that's the widow duel one again
philadelphia fusion always gonna come
out on top strike it though there's a
big triple on the barrage there the
graviton helping both supports are
caught together that's what they needed
but cafe strikes in again
removed what are you doing
[Music]
landing those shots in a high pressure
situation is so tough but carpe just
makes it look easy
at number three we've got a classic play
a candid call and reactions that seemed
nearly inhuman at esl one cologne 2014
cloud9 tico was rotating through mid
doors on his way to a site when he felt
a little tickle from behind but he
turned on his heel and gave us one of
the filthiest head shot flicks in cs
history garrett is going to be waiting
he co charges in doesn't check
oh my god inhuman reactions the call has
become a bit of a meme too but it's
still an incredible shot worthy of
praise
not even with an aimbot could you have
got that kill and nico is still in a 103
almost unwinnable position but that is a
terrifying message to anyone who ever
dares to challenge hiko
at number two entry is also a play that
you may have seen before when you think
head shots in valorem the weapon you
envision probably isn't the frenzy and
yet that's the tool that tens had on
hand against luminosity at the vct na
stage one masters
uh his tens he's got the frenzy
and he's gotta kill man
all up and moves his face and he's
getting a jumping one as well on the
thief i said this the first time i
called tens this is his world and we're
just living in it he's got four he's
going hunting for the ace let him off
the leash he's digging it with intense
aggression tens managed to find four
head shots to take the pistol round for
sentinels he might have even had the ace
and maybe another head shot if not for
six kill right at the end i think uh
they're out of it oh tenza's pissed
he's like bro my ace but i have a
feeling we're gonna be seeing tens clips
for quite a while so i'll forgive it
now if you're a cs head you love a good
spray it's the working shooters play a
trusty go-to a reliable performer but
when you open on an unsuspecting team
you don't expect to get all five and
certainly not with head shots but rox's
surgical spray at star series season
five hits our list at number one and you
honestly have to see it to believe it
yeah that small man actually helped him
with the robs in a great corner sprays
head shots in a row unbelievable and
that's gonna be over time look at oscar
just laughing
what even happened while it's true this
was a partial buy by mouse it's still an
insane spray that should never have
happened but rops has a way of making
the impossible look simple and as an
added bonus this spray forced overtime
and mouse won the map after being down
11 to 4.
all right there we go guys those were
the 10 crispiest headshots of all time
in our opinion we may have missed off
some of your favorites so do let us know
if that was the case also let us know
what you want to see next on the channel
thanks for watching and i'll see you all
in the next one well there we go guys
those were some of the best headshots
that we could find but obviously
people's heads get shot everywhere
people's heads get shot can i say that
and take all three xms with the d
suddenly turns this around though she
gets the angle happy gonna go down oh
excellent there was a player up here
towards that oh my actually quite
reasonable and shapiro tries to beat him
in one five shots five shots five kills